hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 22 video next week
is the finale and then the week after
that is going to be the finale of the
flash so we are slowly shutting down
this season there were a couple things
with the characters that I feel like the
episode didn't address so I'm wondering
if the finales gonna follow up on that
or if there were just like a bunch of
scenes this season that help develop
characters that they had to cut for time
really not talking about a lot of the
supporting characters mostly katana and
Masayo scenes both in the flashbacks and
in present day but I'll try to address
that as we work through WTF moments so
here we go careful for spoilers so
starting with number 5 the Omega has
gone off and Akio needs a cure so they
tracked down Shrieve in the flashbacks
Shrieve says there is no cure but in
modern day Rachel Ghul said the Tatsu or
katana ever you want to think about her
was inoculated so either Shrieve is
lying or they developed an inoculation
after the fact this is gonna be really
important for what happened to team
arrow at the end of the episode so just
remember even though she Reve said
there's no antidote there is a way to
inoculate people against it because this
is such a big plot point I feel like
there will be a scene in the finale that
will address how Tatsu became inoculated
onto number 4 surprise surprise Oliver's
been faking it this whole time it's been
a fairly convincing performance so hats
off the Stephen Amell for playing zombie
ratio Mel the problem is is I feel like
they made the reveal too early in the
episode it kind of undercuts some of the
tension because you remember the rest of
team arrow thinks that he's still drunk
the kool-aid how could you do this to us
Oliver you know like that big moment at
the end of the episode because we knew
Oliver was faking it the whole time it
just it just kind of destroyed some of
the tension it's almost like there's no
threat it's like yeah they're dying from
this poison but Oliver is probably gonna
save him in the end because he's not
brainwashed here's what I think might
have happened they wanted to open the
episode with a big WTF reveal like you
remember after the mid-season finale
Oliver dies and they revealed that he's
still alive in the next episode you
didn't have to wait long at all because
there's so many things going on in this
finale that they have to accomplish and
there's so many characters the writers
may have felt like making the Oliver
reveal early in the episode was better
than waiting til the end or even waiting
to the finale that might have felt more
like a deus ex mash in a situation on to
number three the new team arrow gets
katana this is
another one of those moments meant to be
a WTF reveal like holy [ __ ] its katana
she's got her blade we saw her in the
promo in her armor which was kind of
kind of a spoiler image but she's an
awesome character so you know so you
forgive it you're like okay we have
katana on the team you kind of see why
they brought her in this way because
they wanted to have the Masayo katana
fight at the end that like that's been
their arc this season the problem with
those two characters is is I feel like
they don't have any chemistry on-screen
together conceptually they're both
really interesting but I feel like they
would have been better off just telling
the story of katana from the comic books
just keeping a little bit simpler it's
just that I was never a fan of the
Masayo character I would have liked it a
little bit more if they would have just
swapped the characters is that they were
talking to each other in English you
think it'd be more personal if they
talked to each other in their native
tongue remember they're from Japan but
Oliver met them in Hong Kong because
they were on the run katana never really
explained what she was running from so
they might get into that in season 4
hopefully katana will be back even if
it's only a cameo she's like one of the
biggest DC characters that they brought
on the show so it makes sense that they
would want to develop her more if the
actress is available that's another
really big issue the arrows had just
because they run for 23 episodes it's
really hard for them to cast guest
actors for a long run as for a comic
book katana as we see at the end of the
episode I feel like she's fine I feel
like she just hasn't gotten any
character development so just bring her
on screen more everything will be fine
oh it's number two new team arrow Battle
Royale
just from a production standpoint this
was the biggest action scene that
they've done all season conceptually
it's another really awesome scene you
have all of this new team versus the
League of Assassins and Oliver but
because they're on a TV schedule they
just they don't have quite as much time
to film the action scenes so it feels a
little jerky and uneven just that the
pacing of it and the way they cut
between the scenes was a little weird
too like you go from Ray Palmer giving
Felicity the company which is like a
whole of the big thing we left to talk
about later to them landing in Nanda
Parbat in an open battlefield so the
battle is really awesome but the way
they edited it was just terrible
the other big reason for this big
outdoor battle scene the reason why it
was during daylight outdoors is because
they wanted to do the Adam scene in the
air him flying around versus the plane
remember they have a spin-off coming
that's going to feature
the atom heavily so they want to show
him off they want to get people more
excited about what he can do I feel like
the effects look solid the actions great
I feel like they need to work on the
quippy dialogue just a little bit
they're almost there
but it's another one of those issues
that can be solved by just developing
Ray's character more and finally my
number one WTF moment Oliver and mrs.
wedding I was so happy when she tried to
stab him right after stepping up to the
altar that felt like a totally genuine
moment of course she's gonna try and
kill Oliver the minute they revealed
they'd be getting married to team arrow
all I could think about was the Graduate
you know what dustin hoffman's like
banging on the glass trying to get her
to not marry the dude you just see
Felicity Smoak just banging on the door
don't get married the real question is
is how's this wedding gonna end you know
probably in another big pitched battle
and team arrow in the cave with the
poison just address that what I think is
happening is either someone's gonna rush
in with an antidote that they've created
or team arrow has been inoculated
without them knowing about it
when you try to cut on a WTF cliffhanger
like that and then put those characters
in the promo sounding fine talking to
the flash characters you know that
they're gonna be fine so that's a bit of
a spoiler issue with promos it happens
all the time though so you kind of get
used to it I did mention it on Twitter
but just in case you guys don't know the
people that make those promos the people
that make trailers for movies for
everything are not the same people that
are like the writers the producers on
shows and movies like for example Marc
Guggenheim Stephen Amell the writers on
arrow
they don't make the trailers it's like a
marketing department somewhere else
their job is just to get more people to
watch the episode so they're gonna put
like all the big WTF they can't in the
trailer here's my big question for you
guys though you know now that we've seen
the promo and we know the flash is
coming on Italy at least in some way how
do you think he's going to help team
arrow it could be anything from him just
knocking out all the League of Assassins
to stealing the Omega to full-blown time
travel and just to be clear I'm gonna be
really surprised if it's time travel I
don't think it's gonna be something like
that here's some of the more fun Easter
eggs in the episode so katana of course
herself a really big comic book
character we see her in the costume we
see the soul blade not expecting the
arrow version to have magical powers
like the comic book version but you get
the idea
Roy tells Thea that she always looked
better in red
so if that's probably gonna be with the
color of her costume is she will be
speedy from the comics but she's gonna
be more like the Mia Dearden speedy
Merlin says be at Ferris air by tomorrow
morning Carol Ferris obviously big Green
Lantern Easter Egg and then when Rachel
gold tells me said that her punishment
will be worse than a thousand deaths
it's a nice Easter Egg for this comic
book art with Nyssa and Talia al Ghul
so Nyssa and Talia are half sisters he
talked a little bit about mrs. mother
how she was a concubine not a wife
obviously his wife is the one who had
Talia but in the comics Nyssa is way
more hardcore so in order to stick it to
Talia she kills her throws her in the
Lazarus Pit and then rinses and repeats
and just keeps doing that over and over
and over to drive Talia mad so raychel
goal could literally kill you a thousand
times just because he could kill you
then bring you back in the Lazarus Pit
then kill you again and just keep going
and going and going I say of all the
things this season that has been most
fun especially the back half of the
season has been looking at the culture
of the League of Assassins because of
some of the things they were setting up
in this episode I'm not sure if we're
gonna see a lot of League of Assassins
next season if we're gonna go back to
Argus because we have this big hive
storyline and now that Felicity is gonna
be CEO of Palmer tech Queen industries
but you know whatever their joint
company is we're plugging to spend a lot
more time around that by the way though
there is a long tradition of comic book
superheroes giving their companies to
other people so that they have more time
to play with their toys Ironman is just
the most famous example like Tony Stark
giving his company to Pepper Potts so
that he can just go off and be Iron Man
full time it's a big upgrade for
Felicity's character too so I think that
they're gonna be spending a lot more
time developing Felicity's character in
season 4
especially if her father ends up being
the main villain some of you also asked
if Felicity's gonna give Oliver the
company back now that she has it I don't
think that's gonna be the case I think
it's just gonna be a funny situation
whereby he kind of gets his company back
but Felicity is still his boss you can
kind of see the comedy that will come
out of the role reversal so don't forget
new episode of arrow next week be sure
to subscribe to get my video and then
the week after that will be the flash
finale so you can understand how they're
doing like a two-part crossover so bye
guys wait for that stuff you can click
here for this week's episode of the
flash and you can click here for my
agents of shield video that I just
posted if you haven't seen it yet
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow